- You little characters have no idea
who's sitting in front of you right now.
(audience laughs)
You're about to shit your fucking pants.
(upbeat music)
You've got your perspective.
You just wanna be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
(upbeat music)
What I'm gonna do is give
you guys a little bit
about my background, spit a couple things
that are on my mind that
I think might be valuable
for your life, and then, hopefully,
maybe even do a little
bit of Q&A with you guys
because I think that matters, as well,
so it's really fun to be here
because when I think back
to my childhood, and school, in general,
I have a really interesting
relationship with school
because I was an atrociously
bad student, right?
My whole life, I got Ds and Fs, right?
So I'm not so sure how well
of an opening line that is
for the mentors, and
everybody else, but I think
it's super important for you
to hear where I'm going with this.
It doesn't mean that you
should go and get Ds and Fs,
and things of that nature,
but what I'm gonna speak to
you about is where I come from,
what got me to where I am
today, and that's not predicated
on how successful I am
financially, or reputation wise.
I sit in front of you
today as a 43-year-old man
who's extremely happy,
and happiness, to me,
needs to become the thing that
everybody tries to achieve,
whether they're sitting here,
or they're sitting back there,
even though they're much further along,
so I was born in the former Soviet Union.
I was born in the small
country called Belarus,
which was part of the
Soviet Union near Russia,
and that part of the world, near Poland.
I came to America when I was three.
We were unbelievably poor.
I lived in a studio apartment in Queens
from the ages of three to six years old
that was literally the size of the stage
that I'm on now with five
other family members,
so I came from a really
early rugged place.
We didn't speak the language.
The economy was bad, so
it was hard to get jobs.
It was tough.
The only thing my parents knew
was to try to get different jobs.
One of the jobs that my dad got
was to work at a liquor store.
So he worked, making two bucks an hour,
stocking shelves in a liquor store.
He didn't go to school in America.
He couldn't speak English.
He just had to provide for his family.
We lived extremely humbly my whole life.
My dad worked very hard.
We saved every dollar.
I went on one family
vacation my entire childhood.
It's just the life that I lived.
It's where I came from.
We eventually moved to New Jersey
after my dad became the
manager of that liquor store,
and we made a little bit more money,
and we were able to move to New Jersey.
In New Jersey, at the age of six,
I started my businessman,
entrepreneur career, right?
If I could wish all
66-plus of you one thing
besides health, I would
wish you self-awareness.
Self-awareness is an understanding
of who you actually are,
versus who you wish to be,
who your parents wish to
be, who even your mentors
wish you to be.
It's you understanding
who you actually are.
At a very young age, I knew who I was.
I was a kid that loved to make money.
I was a kid who, instead of
going outside and playing,
wanted to sell lemonade,
wanted to shovel people's snow,
wanted to rake leaves,
wanted to wash people's cars.
I wanted to do stuff to get money.
That's just who I was, and it
wasn't even about the money.
I didn't wanna buy stuff.
It's not like I wanted to buy a Nintendo,
or a football.
I just loved the game of
trying to build a business,
the same way you might
love playing a video game,
or playing a sport, or
reading, or I don't know
what you love, but what
I loved, what I loved
was having a business.
Now, right now in America,
being an entrepreneur,
having a business is cool.
When I was growing up, and I was your age,
it was not.
The only way out of my tough situation
was to go to a great
college that would help me
get a job.
That's what I grew up with.
That's what they grew up with.
There was one path in
America that everybody
was talking about, which
is get a great education.
Now, that worked for a lot of people,
and by the way, it's gonna work
for plenty of you, as well.
I'm sure many of you in
this room wildly understand
that you are quite fortunate
to be within this ecosystem,
and it's going to give you opportunity.
The problem is, and I'm
sure this, I'm not sure
if this is on the agenda.
This is, I hope I'm not
breaking anything here, Ted.
The problem is, how old are you guys?
(students chatter in background)
Great, amazing, so at
11 and 12, at 11 and 12,
I already knew who I was.
At 11 and 12, I was
already going to malls,
and hotels, and selling
baseball cards at shows.
When I was 11 and 12, I
was making $1,000 a weekend
selling baseball cards.
I just was.
How?
I had no money.
My parents had no money.
What did I do?
When it snowed, I went to people's houses,
rang their doorbell, and
asked them to give me $1
to $5 to shovel their
yard, and they said yes,
and then, I worked for 30 minutes,
shoveled somebody's yard, got five bucks,
or in the summer, I
got lemonade, I set up,
I did a lemonade stand.
I did things.
I didn't have the internet.
There was no internet for me.
How many of you have a smartphone?
You guys have Instagram.
You guys have Twitter.
You have the internet, thank you.
I didn't have that.
What I had was my
neighborhood in New Jersey,
and I could hustle and
make money, and I saved,
and then, the same way for you guys now,
people care about things
like Yeezys and Supremes
and stuff of that nature.
When I was your age,
that was baseball cards.
Everybody in my class wanted cards,
they wanted sports cards.
They wanted Greek Freak rookie cards.
They wanted Steph Curry rookie cards.
They wanted that, right?
So I took the money that
I made from shoveling snow
and lemonade, and I started buying cards,
and I'd buy somebody's card for two bucks,
and I'd sell it to somebody
in class for four bucks,
and I worked slowly, and
surely, and every day,
and by the time, it's crazy to look at you
because you guys look young
as hell to me right now.
To look at your faces,
and realize I was already
doing baseball card shows for real,
and making that money,
well, what's crazy is
you have a much bigger advantage over me.
You do actually have Instagram.
You do actually have Twitch.
You do actually have YouTube.
You have that.
I didn't, and so, I sit and look at you,
I laugh when people think
that you're so blessed
to sneak into this little
group, and that education,
and that's great, and that's right,
and a lot of the human
principles, and friendship,
and stuff of that nature, Ted's right.
I promise you something right now,
and this is going off the script again,
you actually having a
friendship with the kid
to the left and right
of you is gonna matter
a hell of a lot more when you're older
than the reading level you're at,
or if you learn calculus eventually.
That's just life.
That's how I see life.
Now, that's for me
because I was self-aware
because I wasn't a good student,
and because that's what I was.
Some of you may be geniuses in science.
You may fall in love with reading
because you never did it before.
That's you.
You need to be you, but
let me tell you this.
The hardest thing at
this age is to be you,
and not let other people's
voices into your head
to factor into who you should be.
The hardest thing right now
is to not do what you love
because it's not cool,
or nobody else likes it,
or grows with it.
That's the hardest thing.
It's hard at this age to love kites,
or to love surfing, or to love
reading when it's not cool.
It's easy to love Supremes and LeBron.
Everybody loves Supremes and LeBron.
I don't like LeBron that much either.
(audience laughs)
But let me say this, and
let me say it very clear
to all of you.
You are living in the
greatest era to be alive
of any human being ever
because you have the power
of the world in your pocket,
and you don't know that
because you've never known no different.
You don't know a world
without an internet.
The fact that you can
start an Instagram account
tomorrow, tomorrow about
any subject, about anything,
and a year from now, people
are willing to pay you $500
to post a picture on that
account blows my mind,
and if that's in you, and you love that,
you need to take that
very, very seriously.
It just is.
People are gonna, you're
gonna hear messages
from where you live, and in this class,
and they're gonna come
in both different places
about how fortunate you are here,
and how tough you have it
there, and the reality is,
honestly, in my heart, I
just genuinely don't think
those things matter as
much as everybody else
in this room does.
I think what matters the
most is that you have
the internet, and regardless
of where you're from,
or how it's supposed to play out,
every teacher in my life told me
I was gonna be a loser, straight up.
It's just the truth, and by the way,
I'm not mad at them.
It was the 80s.
We didn't have to be that
politically correct back then,
and when you get bad grades,
that's what your teacher thinks,
but inside myself, I always
knew that wasn't true.
I knew what I liked.
The reason I had a very
happy school career
is peer pressure never penetrated my dome.
I always knew who I was gonna be.
I didn't care what was cool
or not cool at the time.
I just knew that I was gonna do my thing
because I loved it.
I didn't care that selling baseball cards
went from cool in sixth grade
to not cool in 10th grade.
I kept doing it because I loved it,
and I'm gonna give you another really good
piece of advice.
All those voices that tell
you no, can't, not as good,
whether that's your aunt, your neighbor,
your older sibling, or even,
your parents, they're wrong.
Life's about yes.
It's just the truth.
It's just unbelievable, my man.
It's just unbelievable
how much opportunity
you guys are gonna have
the rest of your life.
It's just unbelievable.
It makes no sense.
Boys that look like you in the 80s lost.
Boys that look like you
in the 2020s are gonna win
because the generation I grew up with,
and they grew up with,
the system wasn't as good
for us that grew up with nothing.
The next generation,
because of the internet,
the system is benefiting the people
that know what it's like
to struggle or fight.
It's hurting the people that are entitled,
and are soft, and have it easy.
You guys have a blessing
in your circumstance,
and I don't think people
are telling you the truth
about how big the blessing is, and how big
the opportunity is.
That's my truth.
That's what I think is happening.
I think that you need
to start communicating
to the world about the
things you're interested in.
The reason most of you haven't started
an Instagram account
or put out more content
is because you're worried
about what other people think,
or if you don't get enough likes,
or all that other crap that
everybody worries about.
It's called insecurity.
You actually worry about
what the other person
sitting next to you thinks.
I understand it, I
respect it, 99% of people
live life that way, but the reality is,
the quicker you figure out
how not to factor that in
is the quicker you're gonna
get real happy, real fast.
(upbeat music)